Amazon Retouren reizt mich jedes Mal
aufs Neue vor allem aber Multimedia
Paletten mit echten Premium Produkten
die sind zwar teuer aber es macht auch
unfassbar viel Spaß sie auszupacken viel
Spaß mit einem neuen Unboxing Video und
damit erinnert was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen Video ich
hoffe natürlich euch geht's gut wir
haben heute wirklich mal was Besonderes
vor und zwar ihr wisst es ja ich handelt
schon sehr lange mit Amazon Retouren das
meiste davon zeige ich gar nicht mehr
auf Youtube eigentlich fast nie aber wir
haben jetzt mal wieder was besonderes
und zwar haben wir eine Palette die
wirklich ein unfassbar großen Warenwert
hat wenn man eine Amazon Retouren
Palette kauft sind am meisten 6 einzelne
Kisten drauf oder halt die ganzen
Produkte drin sind und meistens beläuft
sich der Warenwert auf fünf bis 15000 €
alles drüber ist dann schon echt viel
und die Palette die wir heute offen hat
einfach 27000 also das ist schon echt
heavy ist halt Multimeter ich glaube mit
über 700 Artikel oder so deswegen können
wir auch nicht einzeln auf ihren
eingehen sondern einfach nur auspacken
und schauen ich wünsche euch viel Spaß
mit dem Video wir haben noch einen Gast
dabei macht und jetzt geht's los so
Leute dann haben wir jetzt hier die
Palette um dies im heutigen Video geht
das ist mit Abstand teuerste Amazon
Palette die ich je hatte auf meinem
Kanal und ich glaube auf ganz Youtube
sogar zumindest Youtube Deutschland weil
es ja echt viel du kannst immer kurz
erzählen was war die teuerste Palette
die du hier hattest wir hatten war plus
minus 40.000 € Multimedia Palette 27000
natürlich auch ordentlicher drüber ne
also schon viel Geld auf einer Palette
immer wieder atemberaubenden sind
natürlich ausschließlich Multimedia
Artikel oder sonst kommt man glaube ich
nicht so schnell auf den hohen Wert ich
bin echt mal gespannt aber ich freue
mich jedes Mal aufs Neue wenn ich so
schön so Amazon Kissen übereinander sie
ist eigentlich immer geil
okay Leute was geht wir sind jetzt hier
bei mir im Lager und tatsächlich stehen
ihr jetzt sechs dicke Amazon Kartons das
ist Manuel was geht alles fit ich hoffe
du hast gut hierher gefunden wir haben
schon öfter mal miteinander gearbeitet
und jetzt ist er mal vorbei gekommen und
hat mir schön was mitgebracht und wir
machen das heute zusammen auf ja würde
ich sagen und du bist heute neben mir
noch ein Experte Experte weil ich würde
sagen du hast auf jeden Fall noch mehr
Plan als ich du machst es auch schon
länger nee 2018
aber sonst
wir müssen natürlich jetzt erstmal
schauen ob die Waren die wir jetzt
gekauft haben oder die ich von dir
gekauft aber auch gut sind was man auch
direkt sagen muss wir haben jetzt nicht
extra für ein Video hier was krasses
zusammengestellt das sind fertige
Paletten die er auch so bekommt ne weil
sonst sagen die Leute immer ja ist ja
nur cool du hast jetzt ein Video gemacht
äh ist ja einfach nur zusammengestellt
und ansonsten da ja viele mich immer
fragen wo ich meine Retouren herbekomme
unter anderem oder oder wie man so
Retouren kauft das ist natürlich in
erster Linie für Leute die das auch im
größten Stil machen ne man kommt jetzt
nicht mit 200 Euro zu dir und kann eine
Palette kaufen so ist leider nicht da
könnt ihr dann vielleicht zu mir kommen
ja aber ansonsten du machst ja auch
Instagram viel ne ich glaube da kann man
dich ja dann am besten erreichen ja
instagram ist auf jeden Fall super okay
gut und dann ich bin echt gespannt und
auch ein bisschen nervös weil so viel
hatte ich auf einer Palette noch nie ich
würde sagen wir spannen euch nicht
länger auf die ja und dann einfach rein
okay ich will ein bisschen nebenbei mit
dem Handy mit damit es für euch besser
ersichtlich ist und wir schauen mal ich
freue mich natürlich immer über Produkte
High End Produkte die erste Kiste ist
jetzt doch nicht auf den ersten Blick
zumindest nicht so Frechheit okay wir
gucken mal ein bisschen rein Erika
Mustermann oder nicht Erika
geborene gab Erika doch natürlich auch
ja das ist mein ganz klar sagen muss
also wie gesagt die Palette so super
sehr schön auch definitiv immer eine
tolle Marke oh hier haben wir Apple
oh wir werden noch was für dich jetzt
sagen selfie Leute dass wir die
reingelegt haben aber das stimmt nicht
das ist aber halt auch ganz normal auf
Youtube weil wenn wir jetzt hier direkt
airpods haben das ist ja okay es kann
natürlich sein dass da noch mehr airpods
drauf sind muss die direkt ausprobieren
ah okay also die waren auf jeden Fall
schon in irgendeinem Ort drin so Leute
ihr könnt jetzt hier sehen ich bin
tatsächlich damit connected das Gute ist
auf jeden Fall schon mal die airpods
funktioniert und ich hatte echt lange
keine Airports mehr drin die tadellos
funktioniert haben deswegen ich hatte
jetzt zwar bisschen Ohrenschmalz von
irgendeinem Fremden nicht ganz in meinen
Ohren aber gutes Airport funktioniert
schon mal wir könnten noch ein bisschen
weiter drin
Gigaset auch schon mal eine schöne Marke
definitiv
hier ist auch wieder ein Telefon drauf
ach guck mal hier so eine
Freisprechanlage für zu Hause glaube ich
ne elektrische okay ich glaube sogar
ziemlich teuer
was die Sachen wert sind was man hier so
beiseite legt wo man nicht na ja okay
Leute das war jetzt die erste Kiste da
war jetzt okay die Airports waren ja
schon Highlight Produkt sonst haben wir
jetzt kein mega Ding aber wir machen
einfach weiter auf ist das üblicherweise
wenn man Retouren Kauf bei euch man
kriegt auch eine Liste ne komplette
Bestandsliste und in dieser sieht man
dann genau was auf jeder Palette drauf
ist ich würde auch eigentlich nur
empfehlen so Ware zu kaufen ob man dann
natürlich keine Überraschungseier
ziemlich viel Schreibwaren tatsächlich
sind hier Schreibwaren mit dabei liegt
einfach daran dass diese Kategorie von
Drucker und so weiter und so fort
Drucker Zubehör ist halt nur mal Papier
und das ist mit bei Multimedia drin bei
Amazon
ist glaube ich besser geht schneller
dann machen wir jetzt folgendermaßen wir
suchen uns die hIGHLIGHT Produkte raus
und will einmal durch und dann geht die
nächste Kiste
ich suche mir das was ich denke was am
teuersten ist raus und du suchst dir das
was du denkst am teuersten ist raus hä
was waren das jetzt von Deutsch okay
Fang du mal an mit dem deiner Meinung
nach teuersten Produkt auf der Palette
die sind teuer glaube ich die Store
airpods noch mal Airports hier Ports
okay fast aber ja ist ja ungefähr das
gleiche hast du kein Iphone nein krass
das stimmt also sind auf jeden Fall
super viele Kopfhörer drauf und auch
einige wo ich weiß dass sie echt
ziemlich viel kosten
und window ja ich glaube das könnte
durchaus etwas wert sein ja du willst
das okay jetzt bin ich dran ich glaube
also ziemlich entscheiden zwischen den
hier obwohl nee nicht Logitech Headset
ich nehme einfach mal das bin mir nicht
sicher aber ich denke das kostet 100 €
warte aber vielleicht gehe ich auch
falsch 76 kostet nee zwischen 40 und 76
im Internet gehandelt
vermutlich schon so dann schauen wir
jetzt mal was meine Logitech Kopfhörer
sagen ähnlich also wobei ich habe die
hier schon teilweise für 113 so teuer 66
ich sag mal dann haben wir ungefähr
Gleichstand Unentschieden
zu sagen wie viel dieser Artikel jetzt
zum Beispiel wert ist oder dieser oder
irgendein anderer der hier liegt
deswegen empfehle ich immer sich unsere
Liste anzuschauen und jeder Artikel
aufgeführt auch in so einer einmalige
Nummer und dort sollte man sich das dann
einfach anschauen in der Liste was die
Artikel wert sind und seine Palette
demnach auch über die Liste heraussuchen
und nicht über Fotos oder sonst Paket
Nummer 3 schauen wir mal oh das sieht
geil aus
einiges ja das ist ich würde sagen wir
suchen einfach beide mal uns zusammen
durch oder warte kurz gar nicht mal so
günstig die Marke kenne ich JBL Headset
wir haben wieder ganz viel für
Schulkinder zwei PS5 Spiele
vorbei ich glaube das ist schon ein
bisschen älter
okay was haben wir noch irgendwas
okay
also man muss halt hier ganz klar sagen
die Menge macht ne also du hast übelst
viele kleine Kopfhörer Mäuse Tastaturen
was weiß ich die halt auf die Menge
gesehen dann irgendwann bei wenn man
jetzt halt sechs Kisten davon hat über
20.000 € landen
definitiv empfehlenswerter als einfach
nur ein Highlight Produkt zu haben oder
dass Leute eine Palette nehmen wo drei
teure Artikel drauf sind was machst du
wenn alle drei kaputt sind und schläfst
du da wir haben hier LG Ton free
Kopfhörer die Kosten auf jeden Fall 99,0
neu
hattest du sonst noch irgendwas
krasser sehr interessant könnte ich
finde das hier sehr interessant Slater
also diese smartwatches Kosten auch alle
um die 100 €. ja guck mal rein guck mal
da rein was ist ein aid translator es
sieht aus wie ein Handy das ist
anscheinend einen schwanzlator wir haben
gerade die dritte Kiste wieder
zusammengeräumt und hier sind auf jeden
Fall noch einige krasse Sachen bei
gewesen allein schon hier die Galaxy
watch 4 die liegt auf jeden Fall bei
mehreren 100 € würde ich sagen nee
Handy Pixel 6a das ist doch ein Handy
oder ach krass lol dass ich dachte das
wäre eine Powerbank ich hatte noch nie
selber einen Google Pixel was schätzt du
ich hätte gesagt 250 359 neu und das
lustig werden einfach fast übersehen und
als Powerbank wieder rein also das war
dann auf jeden Fall bis jetzt die beste
Box würde ich sagen aber geil weiter
geht's
mal schauen was noch kommt endlich
wieder geile Zähne mit Oral-B und was
ich auch aus Erfahrung weiß kurz er ist
auch immer viel wert sehr geile Marke
zum zocken und Leute ich werde euch auch
am Ende noch mal die Liste von der
Palette einblenden damit ihr sehen könnt
wie übersichtlich das eigentlich sein
könnte und ne sehr schon ganz cool sowas
wir machen jetzt hier die nächste Kiste
auf ist für mich sind Kisten und
Paletten meistens gleich aber ich weiß
das stimmt nicht so eins zwei
wie Sie sehen Microsoft Surface ist geil
das ist schon mal gut
okay
ich wollte jetzt auch anfangen zu singen
vielleicht dafür
1 2 3 und Abfahrt
Alter ist aber auch gefährlich
Texas Instruments wer hat dich nicht
gehabt in der Schule ich nicht ich kann
das gar nicht nee noch was oder machen
wir die nächste auf gute Frage also das
alles zusammen waren wir auf jeden Fall
über 4000v mit Sicherheit also man darf
es einfach nicht unterschätzen wenn ihr
jeder Artikel seine 30 40 Euro im
Durchschnitt werde ist diese manche
diesen 100 € teilweise sogar noch mehr
wert das darf man einfach nicht
unterschätzen definitiv nicht also ich
mache das schon sehr viele Jahre
definitiv aber man darf niemals
unterschätzen was in diesem
multimedia-boxen drin ist niemals also
es ist unfassbar und unvorstellbar was
für ein Wert immer in diesen Teilen drin
liegt wenn man sich so anschaut
irgendwann naja es sind vielleicht 1.000
2000 €, wenn man sich das in der Liste
genau angucken am Ende prüfe man staunen
wie viel wert so eine Palette definitiv
hat ja allein vom Werte wenn man sich
das so anschaut wenn man jetzt sagt okay
das Teil ist 150 € Wert mit Sicherheit
50 sind 200 so ein Handy ist auch
eigentlich immer ein profiwert 250 so
Nokia Handy schon wieder 50 300 € 350
Euro wegen Bluetooth Radio und hat man
direkt schon seine 300 € an Warenwert
natürlich funktioniert und nicht
dahingestellt aber erfahren Wert direkt
schon paar hundert Euro nur mit wenigen
Artikeln okay zwei Boxen haben wir noch
das beste kommt vermutlich immer zum
Schluss du bist vermitteln Cuttermesser
Kugelschreiber und Zollstöcke die meist
geklautesten Werkzeuge mein lieber ein
panasonic-kopfhörer das haben wir hier
eine Logitech Maus keine Welt bewegende
da waren scheint noch ein bisschen sauer
auf die Maus glaube ich so er sie
eingepackt hat ein Philips Telefon hier
haben wir wieder dieses super super
tolle Druckerzubehör könnte ich mir
mittlerweile auf jeden Fall einen
Konzentration das steht schon mal fest
oh hier sind Handys soundcore Liberty R2
Garmin immer gut nein nee das musst du
doch kennen nein ich kann gar nicht so
Google
und habe dann direkt 180 so ein kleines
Gerätchen 180 € und so geht das halt in
dieser Palette immer weiter wireless
Chargers dann ist das denn Mario
Zigaretten kann man bei Amazon
Zigaretten bestellen Alter das sind
einfach Zigaretten drin ich glaub's
nicht hast du das
ich glaube das fällt dann auch unter die
Kategorie Computerzubehör weil die Leute
Rauchen ja immer viel am Computer
SmartWatch geiler scheiß boah eine
Massage gun oh geil portable Massage
dann hast du eine zu Hause ja da ich ja
dieses Jahr 30 werde natürlich habe ich
noch Massage gegangen okay Leute letzte
Kiste steht jetzt an schauen wir mal
rein Zwischenfrage bist du soweit
zufrieden mit deiner Ware ja bislang auf
jeden Fall also vom Zustand her würde
ich sagen sehr gut aus der Inhalt war ja
über die Liste ganz klar ersichtlich und
wir haben schon einige Produkte gefunden
ja auf der Liste drauf sind also bislang
muss ich sagen sieht das meiner Meinung
nach Hause
definitiv
super aus die ist nicht so voll aber
sieht trotzdem geil aus und ich sehe
schon vier Apple Logos also die beste
Kiste haben wir jetzt am Schluss und wir
haben ja nicht absichtlich zum Schluss
genommen leute schaut mal hier wie geil
das Aussie zeig mal rausholen ja
das ist die Leute immer sehen möchten
Apple Apple Apple ich sehe noch ein
Apfel noch mal hier sind wirklich und
man
schon über 1000 € UVP ich will mal
schnell
ist wirklich viel Tolles drin ich
balanciere solange die Airports Hamann
und Kardon boah muss man nicht viel
Ahnung von haben dass man weiß dass das
wert was wert ist ich muss sagen Leute
ich finde auch immer diese kleinen
Kisten ultra geil das ist wie so ein
Geschenk eigentlich für mich Alter hier
ist ein Nighthawk m2 drin
aber es ist ein
DASDING kostet über 300 €
Airport schaut mal Leute von nett hier
ist sogar noch die Folie drauf
guck mal hier steht einfach nur drauf
Apple das müssen wir eigentlich auch
machen Apple
einfach 418 € kostet das Ding also ich
hätte das Teil nicht gesehen ich hätte
jetzt gesagt da liegt eine externe
Festplatte drin für 40 € für paar
versaute Filme oder
ich weiß es nicht das ist ein Beats
Kopfhörer hä lol toll verarscht worden
sieht aus wie eine alte Kamera guck mal
hier ist sogar ein Spiegel bei Hammer
schauen wir mal hier rein mit euch
zusammen sind glaube ich airpods das
sind aber richtige oder weiß das sind
richtig geil
benutzt aber in dieser Kiste haben wir
auf jeden Fall über 8k und verpeten also
hier ist einiges drin allein schon an
diesem Video also 150 200
kommt doch schon hin
meine ich noch über 200 kommt dann auf
die Generation an ne und JBL Flip 6 auch
geil ja für bisschen Musik im Sommer
also das ist echt wirklich ich hatte
noch nie eine Amazon Kiste weil Amazon
betonen kommen ja oft in diesen Kisten
die so gut war gut gemacht
ich würde sagen Amazon weitergeben
wir haben jetzt insgesamt sechs Kisten
ausgepackt ich blende euch jetzt hier
gerne noch mal die Liste ein und ganz
kurz das teuerste auf der Palette war
tatsächlich der Netgear Nighthawk Router
799,99 € UVP kostet ja dann war da noch
ein Router von Netgear bei 541 Sony
Walkman Google Pixel Handy 329 € ganz
ganz viele Apple Airports und ja ultra
viele Kopfhörer also wir haben echt
viele Produkte über 100 €, das schon
nice ja vielen Dank Kontaktdaten zu dir
sind in der Beschreibung verlinkt gerne
ansonsten ich habe ja auch einen Shop da
könnt ihr auch mal vorbeischauen wenn
ihr Bock habt da kann man auch Amazon
kaufen klar und willst sonst irgendwas
loswerden einfach nur jedem wenn er
Amazon Retouren kauft nicht einfach
irgendwas zu kaufen wo man nicht weiß
was drin ist man sollte transparent
informiert werden wir sind sehr
digitalen Zeitalter also kauft lieber
Ware mit Liste dann wisst ihr was ihr
habt und werde dich zu überrascht oder
übers Ohr gezogen oder sonst was also
wir arbeiten tatsächlich sehr
transparent mit dem ganzen gehen sehr
offen damit um und super dabei
Daumen nach oben wär geil abonniert den
Kanal und wir sehen uns nächste Woche
wieder da gibt's sicherlich wieder ein
Reisevideo der Turm Videos kommen jetzt
in Zukunft nicht mehr ganz so hin und
wieder dennoch weil das ist normal auch
Teil meines in Anführungsstrichen
beruflichen Alltag sondern macht es sehr
viel Spaß und ich weiß auch dass einige
von euch auch deswegen sicherlich meinen
Kanal abonniert haben Leute haut rein
Ciao tschüss